big day big press conference you and
Jake have been tweeting you guys have
been exchanging words for quite some
time now
why is now the time to fight him well
the words all came from me calling him
out
at first he never really knew who I was
which is fair enough I told him at the
time the games means you are fighting
for this belt he has his WBC but they
won against Eddie six months later he's
not fighting me
he's now fired me his interactions
double forward mana going up is this
feud real between you guys is is there
hate on your end so if when you say by
real like I don't hate him I'm making
these videos I'm just clouded on him
yeah if he doesn't thing is you expect
someone to clown your back I don't think
he knows how to approach the clown and
back so he took down the video I told
him to release the claim he's now
released the claim but there's no
there's no hatred online maybe he knows
you think at the end of this there could
be a friendship that comes out of this
or is that just off the table what they
gonna fault my flatmate my first I want
to fire up all my flatmate over dirty
dishes so maybe my flatmates don't live
together but who knows maybe things
might pick up as things go on but that's
all I know
yeah I don't know how have you trained
for this like what's gone into the
training we're getting ready for this
training like any professional would
training doing my runs doing my path to
my spar and doing my bag work doing all
the groundwork the SMC the physio the
lot I'm now out in Vegas training at
Bones Adams boxing gym same trainers
that I've had for the past four years
which is Videl Riley and Leon Williams I
believe having a coatsy had from the
beginning does a lot because they know
they know your weaknesses they know your
strengths from the beginning to that end
they know your journey I thought I
swapped in your trainers out is a bad
move so I've been training with the same
guys right now we've got additional
people to the camp
because of how big this fight is I got
stitched around during my raps
I got jeff mayweather watching over on
the pads had seen how I'm doing in
sparring
I actually got smarten tomorrow morning
so yeah we're trying as hard as any
professional boxer would
the fight is January 30th I always think
it's funny to see what celebrities come
out with you guys who will be walking
out with you will be walking out with me
not planned yet just my team just my
team
I don't want it surrounded with me like
even know what their name is I don't
want some random if I change room
looking over the other day
I've lost social car even if Justin
Bieber Salcedo please leave leave I
would have you bought myself I'm getting
ready for a fight war that's what it is
I don't want any celebrities in the
changing room if you win what will you
do
all I do I've been thinking about this
ever since I landed in Vegas I want a
Popeye's chicken sandwich badly traders
won't let me have it and the thing is it
doesn't exist in in England
yeah it doesn't remember I came there
four months ago I ate six today everyone
saying Popeye the chick-fil-a so I want
a Popeyes so that's all good again never
do them lamb I don't know but they are
all over LA so I bet you could find one
sorry for the promo wanna pop eyes if
you lose yeah what happens what happens
I go back to making gaming videos
realistically FIFA's Vince I've always
had a part my channel before I let you
go do you have a message to Jake before
the fight we had a little interview we
had our first interaction for a while
we've got the press conference on one
hour that's what I got a I got again
looking forward see them during the
press conference are you good
oh yes barb words the smart words they
said they remove the table in the press
conference because they know how I'm
like they could think that I'm very a
rag and the table would be going all
over the shop but that's how it is why
this place is literally crawling with
security guards like there
like 50 of them I'm sorry one security
guard following you around
no or the other come I just arrived to
the spot and boom the securio like okay
hello what's your name
Hawaii well good luck to you January
30th and also good luck today I can't
wait to see you guys stay up there
[Music]